my next guest is no joke one of the
hottest musical stars on the actual
planet
right now she is one quarter of the
k-pop super group
black pink and her first solo track on
the ground has topped the itunes charts
in more than
50 countries and she has over 37
million instagram followers so okay
give it up for rose everybody
[Music]
oh my gosh okay i have to start with
this rose
i've never been cooler to my niece than
this moment right now
she is such a huge fan of yours she
actually legit introduced me
to your music i was like oh my god i
love this i would chill with this and we
were listening to you all at my house so
anyway
i know that you're a korean pop star but
you didn't grow up necessarily in korea
right
uh yeah i was born in new zealand and i
grew up in australia
that's such an interesting background i
love i love new zealand and australia by
the way as well
um but your family says that you like to
sing on road trips is that true
ah that's very true um since we lived in
australia we
took a lot of like long hour road trips
like we would take like seven
eight hour road trips and um i sang like
a lot of taylor swift
like beyonce like songs but um i i
really wanted to mention that uh
because of you was definitely part of
that playlist and i think it was on
repeat
i can see it from top to bottom okay i
cannot wait to tell my niece that
because i'm so not cool to her but now i
will be
um thank you for that thank you for the
cred um
well congrats on your new song man i
love on the ground it is such a cool
song
how would you describe your new music to
everyone
i would say this song really resonates
with
me myself there's a part in the song
that says i've worked my whole life
just to get high just to be like look at
me i'm never coming down
but um it eventually says but everything
i need is on the ground and this is just
it's just a song that kind of tries to
keep everybody grounded
yes tell everybody take a moment to sit
back and think about what really matters
you know to us absolutely it's also one
hell of a vibe
it's a really cool song i'm into it so
well when my staff found out that you
were going to be here
they freaked do you mind if one of my
producers asks you a question because
she really wants to
not at all i'd love that okay awesome
please
everybody welcome senior associate
producer jasmine steven everybody
[Laughter]
so jasmine you're a massive kpop fan i
did not know that this is awesome
absolutely like i have been known to
like call out of work
just to fly across the country to go see
axe i didn't do that here i promise you
but like i've done it before well now we
know where you're going to be
jasmine so what would you want to ask
rosie
so rose as you know i'm a huge fan of
yours but i love your puppy hank he is
so
cute so i just want to know what's his
favorite food
what's his favorite color and can i be
his best friend and then additionally if
i can be his best friend can i be his
godparent she
is getting in there she wants it all
rosette
anytime i would love that um
i mean hank is like the cutest puppy i
adopted him i
actually um so in korea there's like a
bunch of people who upload
these um puppies who um are up for
like adoption and um they kind of don't
have a home
and so um i saw him online and this
lovely lady was
kind of posting about him um telling
people to you know adopt
not buy and um i fell in love with him
and he's just so adorable like you said
he does
like he's very good with tricks if i say
nose he would go ahead and like poke his
nose through my um
fingers and uh his favorite food
is uh his favorite food just any type of
dog snack we give him like all these
treats um
he just likes anything to be honest
anything that's related to eating
um and yeah his favorite color i have no
idea
[Laughter]
you'll have to ask um so everybody rose
i love that we're ending there rose
there's no segway um
rosea's debut solo project is called r
and her single is on the ground and it's
an amazing song you gotta check it out
both are actually out right now
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever
[Music]